welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Lieutenant General Sir Graham lamb a
retired British Army officer with 38
years experience and a former commander
of the field army currently he is
spending a semester at Yale as a Jackson
Institute senior fellow teaching the
Middle East and Central Asia module of
its gateway to global affairs course in
2009 Lam stepped down as commander of
the field army and returned to
Afghanistan at the request of General
David Petraeus and General Stanley
McChrystal of the US Army to play a key
role in the counterinsurgency efforts
they're attempting to reproduce the
success in Iraq by persuading Afghan
insurgents to abandon their weapons he
remains the colonel Commandant of the
Special Air Services is a trustee of the
charity walking with the wounded and
continues to undertake work for both the
UK and US government's today we talked
with Lam about his military experience
and how it translates to the classroom
welcome hey thank you thank you let's
begin with your time in Iraq what was
your role there and why do you think you
were so successful I think sir I was so
successful I sense that that that the
contribution was widespread in many ways
I look at General David who's now moved
on to be the director of the CIA
ambassador Crocker absolute story you
know many ways it's the man of the match
for the State Department so there's a
whole range of people
John Allen who's now in Afghanistan who
was out west yeah in and really in many
ways doing The Awakening long before in
fact people were we're talking about
this is a sort of record as a step
change I've been in Iraq obviously
before I've done the first war with
that's why I first met Stan McChrystal
okay which was you know and I knew of
stand before he came in with JSOC and
a great general that was leading at that
time but he was the fastest sharpest
staff officer I'd ever come across every
knows him as a sort of warrior sort of
one meal a day he doesn't eat a lot of
stuff in between time yeah it's but it's
just like grazing the but so I first
known at that time we went into Iraq and
in 1990 and then went back again
obviously 2003 was there for most of
2003 and then went back again as the
deputy to general Casey and then
followed by General Petraeus in in in
2006 I was the deputy to the to the to
the American general that was leading
and that for a Brit was a real privilege
position you know he's a great great man
great great responsibilities but but
it's a Brit you are the Brit you're not
an American so you're the deputy and you
do a lot of stuff but if you try and try
and be an American then I'm making a big
error because you know the idea that
we're just separated by a common
language is complete nonsense you know
the culturally quite different and how
we do business is different but one
contributes in a way to help the effort
and then specifically on some tasks of
which one of those tasks that I was
given was to take forward where
ambassador Cala said who was already
there was looking and exploring
opportunities because were sense was the
time was right for um being able to
break across into and talk to the other
side and how did you do that how did you
manage that
if you've lost the impose quite easy the
UM there's a very dull German who is who
wrote on war called class of it's eight
books and most of them are
unintelligible I don't speak German but
he he had some fantastic insights way
back time but he's his one of his
well-known quotes is you know war as an
extension of politics my sense has
always been that he just didn't finish
the sentence because it should be if
Wars an extension politics - politics it
must return so we're in the military you
know but often people look as his saw in
Europe where
big problem solvers the or was like that
Irish I saw Marty Dempsey the other day
general Dempsey was just doing this
exchange with with general Liliana again
two great Americans you know Irish
comment you know we have a problem for
every solution you know sort of approach
the but but in many ways you know this
presented an opportunity for us to just
look at where the insurgency had got to
and for us to be able to go out and just
see whether there was an opportunity of
exploring a chance to engage with the
other side because if war is an
extension of policies into politics you
must return then you must at some point
in time talk to the opposition you have
to know there's individuals out there
who as we you know the language you use
is reconcilable and irreconcilable the
vast majority of people are all
reconciled even though they may be
fighting you
they are you've got to understand their
grievance you know the whys of warfare
the house of warfare of these countering
these savage Wars of peace you know
really important to understand if you
don't go there then the answer is you
just see this as just being a bloody
match between winning and losing you
know the Verdun will bleed the bones
white you know a million Germans and
French died there and it was just about
the mass of I have more than him I will
win one's got to be smarter than that so
it was really more more diplomacy
perhaps than force no again you know I'm
an old hard-boiled soldier I never was
I'm not gonna die of a heart attack
there's nothing to stop okay so yeah
this this is a hard pretty brutal
business on the one hand people like the
work that Stan was doing absolutely
critical to the out turn in many ways
that there are people there who sit on
the outer limits it's interesting I was
in a meeting the other day or gathering
other day in London looking at the Arab
Spring and talking about Egypt some very
clever people academia people from the
region extrordinary well-informed but
all from the moderate middle space
talking about the street in a way that I
sense they wouldn't understand you've
got to go to the outer limits and then a
little bit further you've got to spend
some time in Hobbes's world and
understand what motivates what drives
and dozens a Cowie you know the that
worthless individual that we we killed
in Iraq you know you obey oh we
slaughter that's not a point of
negotiation there's no dialogue that can
be established there you either
incarcerate him you drive them away or
you kill him so there are people out
there but you do need to understand how
they operate and that little small group
out there you need to buffer on to a
group that are supporting them but
actually in many ways our reconcilable
you just got to find a route how do you
find that route how do you find what
especially since the cultures are
opposite Oh huge Lisa I think there
again we we see languages being the
single point barrier actually in fact
you know people talk about cultural
awareness language skills in my views
you know what my look is looking for is
cultural understanding so for instance
if we were say you weren't vague they
say oh it's urgent
I mean the first thing I've recognized
in many ways is you know I do some
research and understand who you are we
coming from like actually I'm really
interesting your body language I'm
really interested in the tone your voice
your eye contact all these things are
really important because they tell me so
if I've got an agenda which merely says
these are the three points we need to
discuss and you walk into the room and
I'm not paying attention or you walk
into the cave or you walk into the piece
of desert or we join up at some dark
house in some dark place in the middle
of nowhere and everybody's armed to the
teeth and I'm not paying attention I
merely start with point number one the
whole thing goes badly I shouldn't be
surprised because what I should have
noticed is you walked in with an angry
look tense forward-leaning and the first
question I need arises why is a
pissed-off mmhmm and then he turns
around and says well you turn around and
say you killed my son two days ago so I
could have started with point number and
gone nowhere because I had not first
addressed the ROM so there's an
understanding you've got to get to
you've got it sort of but it's not about
negotiation it's about actually just
established
a connection whether it's through a
third party to start with or whether
it's one-to-one which is where you get
to and and you need to then establish
just a dialogue to begin to break down
the misunderstandings which are legion
between both sides see this as a genuine
about an outcome so the outcome is
therefore in fact not that I've got more
troops than you have I've got a hundred
and sixty eight thousand Americans and
Brits and coalition forces and you've
only got a few sort of fellows out there
and that's irrelevant the answers were
absolutely on a level playing field but
it strikes me as this what you're
describing is a new way to do military
whereas historically it's pretty much oh
no no we did this year's I mean I'm a
Brit
yeah the if you look at you know the
great game actually the Russians refer
to and then that's that interestingly
the the the title of the of the this
work we're doing here at Jackson
Institute which is the tournament of
shadows right yeah but but the
tournament of shadows and this sort of
you know we had collectively as soldiers
sailors airmen Marines been doing this
for him for a millennium yeah and then
some
what what is what we tend to look back
to is the near the near past future the
near past which is the Cold War the
Second World War of which these were
great sort of monolithic masses of tank
armies and huge Air Force LeMay bomber
Harris you know sort of fleets that
exactly oh and the answer is you know
the first Gulf War there was a belt that
a hardware
hammering around is sort of you know the
going into Kuwait and they're like so so
it's not to discard that but what we
have is we've almost come back almost
done full firk you know back to the
future type where we find that the
threats we face today some of the sort
of complexities of the environments we
find ourselves in you know it's it's
you're in you're dropped into the mass
of people and as soon as you bring
people into the problem you take away
all the sort of work all the simplicity
that choreography of war between two
massed armies you know cursed
there's no civilians it's just an open
flat space to tank
it's just above maneuver and about in
fact those advantages you came in these
you know sort of savage Wars of peace
you've just got a builder to people that
aren't that you need to understand it's
people back home it's political circuits
people you know the authority which we
refer to and then of course actually
people in the battle space okay that's
based on your success in Iraq you were
asked to help out in Afghanistan did you
employ the same tactics in Afghanistan
or did you need to modify your approach
oh definitely modifying now if you take
merely oh this worked here all sort of
working and and you know it's a bit like
I think there's a Chinese one of the
Chinese parents came to France was asked
the question what do you think of the
French Revolution he said it's too early
to tell I think it's um the awakening
the surge and all those activities in in
in in Iraq you know the Petraeus is the
stammer crystals punk rockers and all
that John Allen's you know the you know
that was a that was a point in time
where circumstances and then you know
Prime Minister Malaki waffle grab I was
a national security adviser the sort of
what I call the understanding from
people like president Talabani
from the Grand Ayatollah Sistani all
these all these people were in the right
place and the right time to create
something the world thing when Stan
ambushed me on I think that's probably
about the right term and I get an ambush
it's just about a gall bed when Stan
ambushed me said he remember I'm retired
already in in a face or a Tommy said
yeah but can you come out and I need you
to come out to to do Afghanistan I said
then
oh by the way he's got a knee there his
wife he's a real star and he says you
know I need you to come out Afghanistan
and I said right you know I mean didn't
take any time didn't I figure out that I
had to do it
sans an old frame you know we establish
in the military extraordinary
friendships
there's a great quote ends with
basically line says you know that these
friendships forged in the cursed
circumstance we find ourselves you know
are simply beyond price
you know so so when Stan turns around
says listen grim I need you he hasn't
thought about it likely he understands
exactly what the implications are you
know I've done 38 years of hard charging
you know just a lot of separation you
know I'm now looking for a sort of you
know bit like sort of whistlers mother
you know and but he knew exactly but he
needed to ask me and so therefore that
was sufficiency it's loyalty trust and
these sort of relationships we have a
quite special so um so for me it was
just a case of turning right up to my
wife and saying hey Mel yeah but but
actually again I mean the girls
understand really well so I said look I
said it stands Stan Lee's dad has asked
me to do this yeah baby traces is in the
loop I said you know and she gives up
no-brainer so I said I'd give him a
calendar I went out for a month I said I
went out there I said I need to look to
see whether in fact that because I
always go out as you'd expect drawing
upon you know it's interesting with the
course we're doing it at the Institute
you know I meet some really bright
people but but but the message we're
saying is they look it's not what to
think it's how do you think you know you
you it's all about this you know you
need you need to see beyond the simple
sort of what I call structure in front
of you you have to go deeper than that
so the approach these is one turns up
with a blank piece of paper you turn
around and say can it be done rather
than saying you've got all your
instincts you got your manuscripts from
the past you've got your sort of
experiences that they're all kind of
play but I said I'd go out I give him a
calendar month so I literally I wrote I
walked out of in my office on the I
think about the 20th of July 2009 and
was landing in Kabul and the 23rd of
August
a month later leaving an absolute
nightmare for Maelstrom back at home and
unfinished stuff you know trying to a
transition from a really comfortable
life where things were all done for you
in the military you know from your taxes
to you sort of daddy data to suddenly in
fact trying to be a semi-independent
lune out there read his reports Nannes
reporting
way in but but said I give him that
account in a month to see whether there
was possibility for something here in
Afghanistan I've been in Afghanistan
before obviously I know we we'd sort of
been in the back in the old days and
then I'd gone in in 2001 when we knocked
off the Taliban been there for the other
party that into a meeting stand out
there again when he was working for I
think general McNeil briefly before I
then headed off to woods refocused down
onto on to Iraq because that's the way
we were going and then I dropped him in
between time yes so so I knew
Afghanistan moderately well from from
from from that from that period of time
but I need to get out spent about a
month just looking at and seeing whether
it was ground here where we were right I
think the report as I read on the
aircraft coming up was you know it was a
serious piece of work it was you know
the stand said you know the situation is
very serious things were not good and I
usually therefore see what's possible I
went out looked around came back and
then sat down with Stan used PowerPoint
I really hate PowerPoint you know I'm a
Brit America's love pop on you and my
dick was about 10 slides rather than 800
and reckoned that there was ground for
us to be able to do something not the
same different arrangement in many ways
we had in Iraq on the to outer limits of
the problem we are facing you had
because it was a sectarian that was the
sort of chemistry that was creating this
Oracle this momentum of chaos the one
hand you had the insurgents on the one
side Sunni based al Qaeda in that and
you had two Shia militias on the other
and it was it was about trying to work
out how to how to moderate that space in
the middle and separate those who were
irreconcilable to a future that in fact
was of their choice in Afghanistan as I
went round the I came across a great
deal of intimidation
it wasn't self-evident perceived and
real intimidation and of course
Afghanistan is a survival society if you
live in a survival society you work only
on the probabilities of outcome so if
you're a family if your individual plan
if you're a tribe then the probability
of outcome if it says the Taliban
returned then you do not go with a white
guy right yeah so you have to change
that dynamic and that's what
last two years as many ways have been
about changing that level of
intimidation around the country well I
you know we you know it's hard charging
Afghanistan are we the Brits would know
this we've been there three times and
got our asses kicked the on each
occasion I think that you know it's eat
it's very easy to take a binary approach
on this of stuff I say that that the the
the the path that was the trend that was
occurring in 2001 has absolutely been
corrected and checked I think Stan
readjusted the campaign you know
President Obama delivered 22,000 Marines
in the February that year he then
delivered another 30,000 in this Oracle
on the call of the sort of a call to
increase the numbers made a significant
difference down in Helmand province yeah
well you ain't got the ratios right
General Petraeus comes in you know the
absolute sort of architected delivery
and somebody asked me other they said
well you know like it actually I saw Big
John Mulholland great general and the
changes responsibilities ceremony
between oriano and general Dempsey the
other day and and and Big John said
pretty we're not making you know we
didn't we didn't see didn't work out in
Afghanistan I said it's too early to
tell John you know it's a different
timeline in Afghanistan things are very
much on a slower burn but I sense the
big moving parts have moved the problem
is that the the outer limits in
Afghanistan from my perspective you know
and again this is just just grim land
speaking in the way of the way I saw it
was on the one hand you had the those
that were fighting us Taliban and the
Associated tribes and the like and on
one flank but on the other side actually
you had oh and and it was interesting
when I went around in that first month
and talked to the Afghans they they
didn't talk about the enemy they didn't
talk about you know sort of the Taliban
is some sort of winter mage some sort of
subhuman class and there were people
there that did not like them at all in
2001 I remember going up to Bamian and
one of the old Hazara elders and they've
been very badly treated by the Taliban
it's where the three bullets were
they've been destroyed all the rest yeah
it's a massive great bear hug and saying
thank you for giving us back our country
you know they had no love at all the
Taliban but but the general word that
language they use you they talked about
these people that were fighting us as
upset brothers so one of their own upset
now pretty upset but but but this is
Afghanistan and as Winston Churchill
wrote very eloquent in 1897 I think it's
this incomprehensible temper for the
Western mind in many ways so so they're
difficult to understand this but but but
these upset brothers the the grouping on
the other side were the communities
because actually Afghanistan is made up
of all these quite separated parts you
know there hasn't been the sort of water
as we would understand it from central
government and placed it's not the way
things were done you know Kabul was only
a point of arbitration and so you had
this sort of balance of power
relationship between the Shires out
there in the valleys and all the rest
year you know the 1940s 1930s when
people talk about the Golden Age you
know what was never safe it was stable
and you had this balance of balance of
power sitting out there but but on this
side you had these in different
communities they were indifferent to us
they were indifferent to the government
they were indifferent to the lack of
progress and the interesting thing was
one needed to deal with that first
before you could really start to move
this view of the Afghan because they're
proud of it you know it's almost they
have this sort of set of this is what my
father did against the Russians and so
therefore this is so this is how I
should respond anyway so I think you
know that was the the view of looking at
but the outcome was I don't understand
said yeah I think that there's something
here we need to set up the structure
it's a slow burn program it'll take a
lot longer than it didn't in in Iraq and
of course other people therefore turn I
say because the awakening from when it
was first seen occurred quickly recently
quickly relatively quickly within a
calendar year you saw the change shift
change all the work that John Allen Jim
mattis did in effect out Western great
US Marines in fact them was brought into
fruition in fact in that following year
you know
in many ways in in Afghanistan you know
in my view you know it's it's three or
four years but the structures are there
the High Council is there who are made
up of Afghans who are known and
respected who don't you know they're not
compliant to us the coalition and so
therefore they have a view into the
government and into the actions of and
they can talk to communities a week you
know I'm white guy you know I can go and
talk to them but actually you know I
can't connect to them and so it's a
different approach of how you do this it
just means everything goes let's talk
about your time now in the classroom and
how you're bringing your military
experience and transitioning it into the
classroom let's actually start with as
someone who's led troops into battle
what do you think it takes to be an
effective leader because obviously the
students here are hoping to one day go
out into the world and be leaders wicked
sense of humor no I I think I think one
of what a one of life's great character
qualities is humility I think that a
reflective and thoughtful mind I think
you know often you know that rather than
I spy with my daughters have tattooed on
their on their feet
fortune favors the brave term of mine as
well but interestingly there's a there's
a great book on German general in the
second world war a fella called Kurt
Meyer he was an SS divisional commander
so his his his political affiliations
were absolutely on the wrong side of
anything I would recognize and in that
one one could hold no cred but as a
combat commander as a combat leader the
answers he was you know Panzer Meyer was
was one of the small group of people
that were exemplary his chief of staff
wrote and it's in a book and it just
disappears in a line yeah but it said of
Kurt Meyer fortune favor'd the competent
yeah and so competency and that's where
these great universities you know Yale
Oxford Cambridge back in UK Stanford
Princeton but you know so it's
absolutely in that spot the turns around
and says this is about
young men and women being given
extraordinary competencies you know I
look at the class I've got you know
there's there's I mean you know I'm I'm
the dumbest guy in the room by some
considerable margin you know these are
really smart people from across the
globe a whole lot of great Americans
yeah they're but but but but really
really smart they have the ability
therefore to pick up the book you know
but if if the the writ of the word year
is all they learn they're doomed it's
the interpretation the reflection their
own experiences and how they look we
yesterday's period was one where we
looked at and and there I'd given them
some reading and at which they could
have I'm sure we almost regurgitated
word-for-word line by line in effect the
structure which they've been presented
with I said but that's not you know what
did you think about it what you know
what came out of it because that's where
they need to go to and they're clever
enough to go there they just a slightly
constrained at the moment in many ways
by the sort of you know the importance
of being able to recite to have the sort
of classical academic now you need that
baseline which I don't have experience
has given me some insights and then you
need to apply it to in fact your ability
to be able to then absolutely project
yourself into a space of it's how you
think rather than what you think about
these things because you know doesn't
matter what's the Middle East whether
it's United States of America South
America Asia or you know they're just
complicated really complicated and if
there is just one thing you'd like
students to take from your class what
would it be
I finished yesterday with a with a quote
from the father of sort of Greek tragedy
which talks about you know once an eagle
you know fallen and it finishes you know
as he looks towards the shaft that is
basically done for him and the feathers
that at the end of it by our own hands
are we smitten so there's a danger that
you look across at issues that are
occurring and one sees them as as others
making where it's quite often our and
how we operate
yeah there's nothing wrong with
intervention you know then today's not
something you know that what we do but
how we then intervene our relationship
with sovereign nations with ancient
civilizations you know when I was in
Iraq you know I used to talk you say you
know here I might you know birthplace of
Abraham you know they were they were
firing ceramics I'm a Scott when we were
painting ourselves you know with woad
and yet somehow we see this as
uncivilized nothing could be further
from the truth it's like the Far East
exactly the same so so there's a real
dangerous we go in with a sort of a near
view of just hard you know United States
the superpower of the day the you know
you know powerful in every sense and but
but their approach of saying this is you
know this is how you should now because
we've got a near-perfect life we've got
a great sort of you know this is the
system we work by you should now adopt
ours reflect on us you say actually what
arrogance we did exactly the same as
Empire well the trick is in many ways to
go in there with a huge dose of humility
and see how one can help individuals in
this case there is a right to intervene
you know that I think you know I was
placed like Rwanda I was in the Balkans
right so I understand why the United
Nations for instance in 2005 made the
finding they did you know the
intervention in Libya you know I
remember intervening in Macedonia we
stopped the third Balkan war that's a
good intervention so the idea the
intervention is wrong or it's somehow
sort of be not good we safe probably
tens of thousands of lives by that and
no one or not many people are shot in
that process yeah so it's this idea that
I think that you know by our own hands
we are smitten so so you have to be
really careful as you go walk into this
ground here that quite often our own
actions or our own attitudes or our an
approach or our own ability inability to
look from the other side of the hill
quite often will give us in fact makers
have as make analysis and or decisions
which are not conducive to success my
final question as
we approach the 10th anniversary of
September 11th as a man who has spent
time in Iraq in Afghanistan how safe do
you think we are in this part of the
world I know we're on a high terrorist
alert today according to the news do you
think we have concerned too worried
oh I think I think it would be it would
be foolish to somehow think that our
interventions of somehow stopped the
tide of evil you know the concern I have
to you know as an old soldier now in
effect you know the as I look to the
future is is the concern that I have is
that you have now the tools of
industrial violence which were those
only afforded to the sovereign state and
certain armed forces now within the
grasp of a few and that is not only
weapons of mass destruction which are
the well known and well done but it's
weapons of mass disorder power
electricity and these things yeah with
that you have this enormous force for
great good or force for imminent for for
great for great evil which is which is
the very medium we're talking here which
is information media you know the
ability to bring assemblages of people
because quite often you know what is
interesting when you when when I came
across the insurgents I was talking with
across cups of tea in the middle of
nowhere in in Iraq was the level of
misunderstanding between the two and
what was what was fascinating was how
Mallen misinformed they were about
intent and and what we were and what we
were doing now that wasn't because of
happenchance it was because a few people
had manipulated an event or two had
taken things into a context and
presented them
Neverending fashion had used some
examples of how we were operating events
occurring and were able to manipulate
and then to motivate and then to
mobilize people through a corrupted
message in order to do great evil when
one sat down and talked through these
things and then quite often you came to
this position at the end where in fact
there was a the dialogue allowed you to
then go into confidence-building
measures then change so so I think that
that the idea that the world is any
safer would be a misnomer the idea that
by doing nothing the world would be
safer is a complete nonsense I sense
that you know we witnesses this is a
hard endeavor it is a it is a conflict
without end and people may not like that
but that's just the harsh reality of of
the 50-minute opportunity that somebody
can have to be somebody without any
sense of the the responsibility of what
he or she is about to do you know the
222 to 2 towers you know our graphic
sort of images the jumpers all that side
of something you just think you know how
could this have happened but if we
somehow think that that you can you know
chasing down incarcerating or killing an
individual is is within the grounds of
you know moving and changing movements
and ideas these are really complicated
these are things which require a huge
investment across all the departments of
State against in fact what I call from
academia through the presidents through
to the military of how we then look at
ourselves and look to the future it's
interesting in part of this work I was
doing with with a Jackson Institute you
know in Mac and you know reread you know
for instance Woodrow Wilson's fourteen
points back in 1920 and a you know it's
fascinating how people looked at this
these great endeavors the approach of
how we should as nation-states rather
than individuals you know make a change
and make a difference not on our terms
but on these collective terms so I think
that you know the sad news is that the
world's remains a dangerous
is a troubled century but so is every
other one been and and so therefore you
need people that are from both sides you
you know long may you know great
humanitarians long may good people like
you know that they're out there that
that want to bring a better life and a
better peace you but but don't somehow
think that just by being good that in
fact evil will somehow just take a take
a knee it won't and therefore you need
to have people who will bring violence
those who will bring you harm in this
world
very good it's been fascinating thank
you so much for being here with us too
my pleasure for more information about
Lieutenant General Sir Graham lamb
please visit our website at Yale GDU
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you